[Music]
hey this is Mel strong and this lecture
is on fronts and mid-latitude cyclones
now in previous lectures we've been
talking about how we can create clouds
and precipitation through convection so
in that story we've got a little parcel
of air it's warmer than its environment
and it wants to rise and as it rises it
expands and as it expands it cools and
eventually it will reach its dew point
and form a cloud if it keeps on going
then eventually you can get
precipitation ok there's a whole
completely different way to make clouds
and precipitation and it comes from the
collision of these large what we call
air masses so here's a map that you
often see in our textbook of air masses
and what they're trying to show here is
that air that sits over a particular
region will take on certain
characteristics and we talked about this
a little bit when we were back talking
about humidity that if you had a blob of
air sitting over the continent it's
probably very dry
whereas a blob of air that's sitting
over the ocean can pick up a lot of
water from evaporation well not only is
there that variable but it's also
depends on the temperature and where it
is so for example up here MP stands for
maritime polar this is maritime tropical
this is maritime equatorial so these are
all blobs of air that are sitting over
the ocean but as we learned when we in
the lecture on the evaporation if you're
sitting over warmer water there's a
higher evaporation rate into the air
mass so the air mass this air mass is
going to have a higher dew point than
say this air mass and we have for
example CPS continental polar CAS
continental Arctic we're not really
going to get into the the names too much
in this class but the point is is air
that's sitting over say this region
which is going to be cold and dry may
mingle with air that's sitting over this
region which is warmer
and more humid and when these two things
interact with each other you're going to
get some very interesting weather as a
result now it's a little misleading I
think this this diagram because a lot of
people might walk away thinking if there
is a blob of air sitting over here all
the time called Mt from air time
tropical but this is just represents
sort of average conditions and these air
masses are always moving around all the
time it's this is just trying to show
that air that sits over here typically
has certain characteristics that are
different than air that say sits over
here okay that's all that really means
so we're going to start today at Earth
will scold net and I'm going to change
the overlay to temperature and when I'm
looking at right now is surface
temperature and I'm doing this on a day
that's in the winter in the northern
hemisphere so what I see these this blue
and purple this is really cold air right
here and so we've got cold air that's
sitting over the continents looks like
right that's kind of what we would
expect we got cold air over Siberia and
Alaska and notice the pretty sharp
change in temperature the contrast in
temperature between the air over the
continent and the air over the ocean so
right now in Northern Hemisphere winter
the ocean is much warmer than the
continent okay now if we did this in the
summer we would see it's probably going
to need to be the opposite the continent
will be much warmer than the ocean and
the reason for this is that the ocean
has a very high what we call heat
capacity so what that means is it takes
a lot of energy to change the
temperature of the ocean so it takes a
long time for the ocean to warm up and
then once it's warm it takes a long time
for the ocean to cool down so the oceans
temperature is always out of sync with
the continents and that's what we're
seeing here okay so what I'm going to do
though is that so this is all surface
temperature and I'm interested in
showing you what the temperature is like
up in the upper parts of the atmosphere
so I'm going to click the word earth and
over here where it says height there are
these numbers
I need 5700 the units are HPA so that's
a unit of air pressure and we learned
this one back in the lecture on air
pressure I only change it to 700 HPA so
what that means is if you end up in the
in the atmosphere and a balloon till you
reached a level where the air pressure
was 700 millibars
what would the temperature up there be
like now how high is that give or take
about about ten thousand feet above the
ground just kind of think of that right
so we're just kind of looking at what
the temperature is like 10,000 feet
above the ground or so and you'll notice
how different the pattern looks compared
to what we just saw for one thing we
don't see the big contrast between the
oceans and the continents anymore and we
see that for the most part if i zoom out
a little bit if why I kind of look
around the middle of the earth I see
that the temperatures around here don't
change that much and then when you get
further to the north of the South you
suddenly hit this much colder blob of
air up there and it's a pretty sharp
contrast so in other words it should not
be surprising that the equator is hot
and the poles are cold but what you
might expect to see is that from the
hottest point on earth it gradually gets
colder as you move to the north or gets
colder with gradually gets colder as you
move to the south but what does this
showing us is actually this very little
change in temperature again remember
we're at least 10,000 feet above the
ground here or looking at this so
there's very little change in
temperature and then all of a sudden we
hit this boundary as pretty sharp where
we go from the warm air to the cold air
very abruptly so there's not a gradation
okay so that's the first observation
second observation is the boundary
between the cold air and the warm air is
curvy right so if I look at the North
Pole I can see it's got these waves in
it and I'm gonna turn around and look at
the South Pole because there's another
one down there it's a little bit easier
to see this time of year
okay so this boundary between the warm
air and the cold air it's called the
polar front okay it's always there it's
always there in summer in the winter but
right now it's there summer down in the
southern hemisphere so their pool of
cold air is smaller and it's winter up
here in the northern hemisphere so our
pool of cool there is is larger and if
we did this in the summer those two
things would be reversed
so what I'm gonna do here is let me go
back to the southern hemisphere because
it's easier to see okay so I'm gonna go
forward in time a little bit here so day
later one day later one day later one
day later each one of these is one day
later and you'll notice that this cult
this blob of cold air is slowly rotating
around the earth so every 24 hours
it's changing its shape and there are
these you know there's parts that kind
of break off a little bit and overall
it's still kind of you know keeps this
it's staying in the same area but the
actual outline of it is changing slowly
day to day okay and these waves that we
see that are in this blob of cold air
are called Roz B waves so you can see
especially in the northern hemisphere
here I've got these waves okay and let
me go back in time a couple of days if I
go back in time a day a day you can see
these waves are changing their shape
okay so the point is we've got this blob
of cold air that is slowly moving around
the poles of the planet and so the the
planets rotating 24 hours a day but and
this blob of cold air takes you know ten
or so days to make a full revolution all
the way around the earth now right here
at this boundary between the the warm
air and the cold air this is where we're
mixing up two completely different kinds
of air masses this is cold dry air this
is warmer more humid air and that
boundary is is what we're talking about
today that front where we're calling the
polar front where these two air masses
meet we're going to get some interesting
types of weather now if I find a zone
here okay so now I've changed it back to
today with winds and I'm looking at out
here in the Pacific and I notice for
example this spot right here so the
winds are spinning counterclockwise
right here or in the northern hemisphere
so that tells you that I must have a
center of low pressure right there okay
now if I'm gonna zoom out a little bit
here you can kind of make out the fact
that we're taking air that's from the
north and it's cold and it's coming down
and then we're taking air that's warmer
and more humid from the south and it's
coming up and these two things are
mixing up together in this big spiral
pattern okay this is what we mean when
we talk about air masses colliding we
have two very different air masses and
this low-pressure center is mixing them
up with them up together now I'm going
to change this instead of temperature
I'm going to change it to look at
moisture so tpw means total precipitable
water and this just looks at all the
water that's in the atmosphere now it's
a little bit more evident that we're
mixing up different types of air so very
cold very dry air coming off the
continent warmer more humid air coming
from the south and we're mixing these
two things together I can turn off the
wind here a little bit so you can see
that right there we're mixing it up we
get a little Center little pressure
right there here's another one or mixing
up again warm humid air with cold dry
air and this is what happens along the
polar front we're mixing up two very
different air masses and right through
here we've got the invasion if you kind
of imagine what's happening here I've
got cold air coming down invading the
warm air and then I've got the warm air
coming up and invading the cold air
right and so these two things are two
different kinds of fronts overall the
pole
front is the name we gave to those that
wavy blob but we can break it down
further because here we got cold dry air
invading warm human air and then up here
we've got warm humid air invading cold
dry air so we turn the winds back on
here so here's you here's where the cold
dry air is invading the warm where they
meet and then this is where that warm
humid air meets the cold dry air ok so
these are going to form two different
kinds of fronts so we're going to be
looking at what happens where these two
different types of air invade each other
so the first one we're going to look at
is what happens where the warm air
invades the cold air so if that happens
and we let's say we make a cross-section
of the atmosphere so we're looking at it
from the side we would expect that the
warm air will be coming somewhere from
the south in our part of the world so
over here is the warm air and it's
headed towards the north it's invading
okay and to the north we have the cold
air that's sitting there so when we
talked about convection what we said was
if I have a parcel of warm air it will
rise because it's warmer than the air
around it which is due to density
differences now here what we're doing is
we're forcing warm air to collide with
the cold air but they still have that
same density difference the cold air is
more dense the warm air is less dense so
what happens is if I try to shove warm
air in the cold air it's going to want
to right up over the cold air and so
that's what happens but it kind of forms
this very low angle ramp so when the
warm air encounters the cold air so so
just to be clear this is cold air down
here in this wedge the warm air then
rises up this ramp it's a very low angle
ramp maybe just a degree or two and it
goes on for perhaps hundreds of miles
okay this is a very large feature well
this air as it goes up the ramp is
rising and anytime you make air rise it
expands and expanding air cools and
eventually you'll hit the dew point and
then you get a cloud so that's what's
going to happen to this Baba warm air
that's down here it's going to go up
this ramp and as it goes up the ramp
it's going to cool more and more so all
the way out here at the edge the top of
the ramp we would have some very high
wispy clouds which we know are Cirrus
and then they get a little bit thicker
and more of a blanket and that's what we
would call zero Stratus and then they
get thicker still and that we would call
altostratus right and then further back
on this wedge we're getting a thicker
and thicker chunk of air and eventually
they would be so thick that we would not
be able to see the cloud sorry wouldn't
be able to see the Sun that's Stratus
and then from behind that point if it's
a well developed this whole thing is
pretty well developed we would have
precipitation coming out of this and at
that point we've got nimbostratus
okay now this whole thing not only is
the warm air writing up over the cold
air but the actual wedge itself is also
moving so this everything on this
picture the way I've drawn it is moving
to our right here
okay well this spot right here where the
warm air meets the cold air that is
called a warm front okay
and it's a call to warm front because
let's say you're right here and you are
gonna experience this whole thing when
this ramp gets to you and passes over
you the experience is that the
temperatures increase because this air
back here is warmer than the air that
you're currently sitting in so in a warm
front the temperatures will increase as
it goes by all right so let's think
about the series of events that would
happen here if you're out here and this
warm front is approaching you now to get
from from this point to this point might
take you know 24 hours could be more
could be less well let's just say that
you're let's just say this this whole
thing takes let's say day and a half
okay so you're standing out here and
this warm front approaches
it's the 1800s and you don't have any
electricity there's no weather stations
nothing like that and you're on your
horse and you look up and you see wispy
clouds in the sky okay and then maybe
four to six hours later you see
cirrostratus remember what that looks
like
it's ringing around the Sun okay so you
went from wispy clouds to ring around
the Sun and then if it's still daylight
fuzzy Sun and then later
no Sun okay so if you notice that
pattern cirrus to cirrostratus to also
stress to Stratus
there's a good chance that it is going
to rain in the next say 24 hours so
people started to notice this pattern
they started to notice that if he saw
this and he saw this and you saw this it
leads to rain so there is some folklore
in certain parts of the world that say
that if you see a ring around the Sun
it's going to rain this is where it
comes from
that is true for a warm front okay now
as we'll talk about in a little bit warm
fronts don't occur everywhere in the
world they occur along that polar front
that zone between the warm air and the
cold air the thing with the rose be
waves if you live in that area
that's true ring around the Sun often
does mean it's going to rain but you can
get a ring around the Sun in a lot of
different places in the world and not
have a warm front so that doesn't
totally hold true ok but that's where it
comes from
ok so this whole thing again in this
scenario is moving past you maybe it
takes a day and a half or so to get from
this point to this point so your
experience would be Sara Sara Stratus
all the stress Stratus and then rain
maybe as much as 24 hours
okay now that spot right there is the
warm front that that spot we can put
that spot on a map so the show a warm
front on a map will have a line with
these humps ok so this is a warm front
and the warm air is back here and the
cold air is on the other side okay so
the warm air is behind the humps and
it's moving in the direction of the
humps okay so this is the the the
literal point on the ground that we had
where the wedge meet the surface in that
previous diagram okay so the warm air is
coming along it hits this cold air and
it ramps up over it so what that means
is that right ahead of let's see right
here somewhere ahead of this would be
our cirrus clouds and then behind that
they get thicker and we get the
cirrostratus right and then the uncle
Stratos and all that but it's a big band
it's a big band ahead of this warm front
so eventually if you're looking at this
from space and we'll see one in a second
you'll see the Cirrus as kind of a fuzzy
edge and then it gets solid white up
until you get to where the warm front
passes now a couple other things
think about dew point for for a minute
the warm air and cold air the warm air
has come from the south it probably came
from an ocean so the dew points are
probably higher and the cold air as we
know the dew points are lower so as this
warm front passes over you you know if
you're if you're out here and you're
seeing that sequence of clouds as this
thing is approaching you the other thing
that changes is when this passes over
you your temperatures go up and your dew
points will also go up okay so that is a
warm front so now let's imagine what
happens where the cold air invades the
warm air
okay same kind of scenario except now
what's going to happen is we've got warm
air over here and we've got cold air
over here but the cold air is now
invading the warm air okay so it's
coming in colliding with the warm there
now the cold air is more dense and it
tends to kind of hug the ground so kind
of like this so it's it's got like
basically tunnel underneath that warm
air and it's gonna throw the warm air up
out of the way
so you got cold air coming down
tunneling underneath the warm air
shoving it up out of the way and one of
the things that you're gonna get right
here right where that cold air meets the
warm air is very likely cumulonimbus are
at least cumuliform clouds so I'll draw
some cumulonimbus here so this rolls
through shoves warm air up out of the
way the warm air rises in these little
pockets and gives you a cumulonimbus and
then what happens is as this thing
passes you know this is pretty cold air
and the ground was kind of warm that it
rolled over you've got will opens a warm
air rising up through the cold air and
you will get all kinds of cumulonimbus
forming
[Music]
in the back as this cold air rolls
through so this point right here that is
the cold front and if you were here and
a cold front is coming towards you your
experience is that you don't really
experience until the front hits you and
when the front hits you boom you have
cumuliform clouds so it could be keenly
less could be towering cumulus could be
cumulonimbus it could be it could be a
line of very severe thunderstorms if you
live in certain areas and then as this
cold front passes over you this blob of
cold air moves past you your temperature
suddenly drops okay so that's what we
call it a cold front and just to remind
you of what we said last time so we've
got low dew points here so cold air is
always dry air as this rolls past you
not only does your temperature drop that
very likely the dew point also drops so
this is so in a warm front then we've
get the stratiform clouds in a cold
front we get more cumuliform clouds so
on a map
the cold front if it's in color is in
blue but either way you're looking for a
line with triangular teeth and the
triangular teeth indicate a cold front
air behind the triangular teeth is where
the cold air is and on the other side is
the warm air and the cold air is moving
in the direction that the teeth are
pointing okay so that's a cold front and
if you can't remember which is which and
if it's black and white would I tilt
when I teaches the kids I tell them that
the cold air is biting cold that's why
the cold front has teeth they helped you
remember great there is another type of
front where the two air masses actually
come up against each other but neither
one wins it's called a stationary front
I'm going to draw that real quick so in
a stationary front you've got teeth on
one side and then you've got humps on
the other side okay so the same rules
apply the warmer is behind the humps and
the cold air is behind the teeth and at
least at this point in time neither one
is really taking over the other
that's called a stationary front so warm
fronts and cold fronts usually occur
together near the same place along the
polar front and we call it at a
mid-latitude cyclone so by mid-latitude
cycle and what we mean is not low
latitudes like the equator and not
really high latitudes like the poles but
somewhere in the middle and cyclone is
another word for storm so you can think
of this as a storm that occurs in the
mid-latitudes kind of along the polar
front
so we're gonna go through the stages of
how one of these form and how they
evolve and then eventually die so it
starts out with essentially a stationary
front along the polar front so what we
have is we've got cold air to the north
so we're you know drawing this from a
Northern Hemisphere perspective right so
if this is in the southern hemisphere
everything would be flipped so we've got
the cold air up here we've got the warm
air down here and right now neither one
is invading the other so we have a
stationary front but it won't stay that
way for long because you've the cold air
side usually has air or winds that are
coming down from the east and the warm
typically kind of has westerlies so
you've got the situation where you have
two different kinds of air masses which
have different densities going past each
other in different directions and that's
not a very stable setup and what's going
to happen is that there will be waves
that develop in this boundary and once
we start to develop a wave we start to
make a meal add to it cyclone so we'll
make a slight wave in that in that front
and we're gonna we're going to form a
mid-latitude cycle okay so we start to
develop a cold front on the west side of
it and a warm front on the east side of
it and so now we've got kind of this
and draw these guys in here we've got a
counterclockwise rotation that's
starting to set up here and in the
center of a counterclockwise rotation in
the northern hemisphere is a low so I'm
gonna draw it there's a center of
low-pressure kind of right between those
two fronts now why is the pressure low
because air is rising why is there
rising well and this one you've got
remember the ramp so you've got warm
they're ramping up rising up over the
cool air in front of it here you've got
cold air tunneling underneath the warm
air and pushing it up out of the way
in both cases air is rising so this
whole thing air is rising but the this
center of low pressure is right in
between it those two types of fronts all
right so now what's going to happen is
the storm intensifies and this
counterclockwise motion is going to
continue so you're going to get
something that kind of has this shape so
the cold front is sweeping around and
then the warm front it's kind of arching
up now think of everything we said
earlier about a warm front in a cold
front like all the clouds and all that
stuff that's happening all the warm
front stuff is happening over here all
the cold front stuff is happening over
here now in our part of the world when
one of these forms this whole thing is
also moving to the east so you have to
imagine as we're drawing this that
there's two things happening one is
you've got counterclockwise rotation so
the Front's themselves are starting to
twist around the center of this and the
other thing that's happening is this
whole business is moving as its twisting
okay so that's the motion of a
mid-latitude cyclone so
as the storm intensifies what happens is
the cold front moves faster than the
warm front and it catches up to it so it
looks something like this and this is a
cold front and this is a warm front so
now this this cold front has wrapped all
the way around and it's caught up to the
warm front and it tunnels underneath the
warm front and so that gets a special
name we put a hump and a tooth on each
side and that is called an occluded
front ok so again that cold air when
it's wrapping around is moving faster
than the warm air perhaps around catches
up to it tunnels underneath now we got
three different fronts here the warm
front the cold front and this occluded
front which is really two fronts on top
of each other now at this point the
storm is at its peak energy okay so the
storm is the strongest but once the
front starts to occlude then it's kind
of like this whole thing's zips up and
as a zips up it shuts itself off so when
the occlusion happens the storm is the
strongest we would say it's in its
mature state and the end is near okay so
also end is near once this happens then
it the end is within you know probably a
day or two so the steps from initiation
to here
depends on lots of factors but roughly
one of these things lasts five days
seven days something like that
so it'll form it'll go through these
stages then these these two fronts kind
of zip together and it shuts itself off
and then another one forms okay that's
the life of a mid-latitude cycle now
what we're going to do is talk about
what it would be like to live through a
mid-latitude cyclone so let's put put a
fairly mature mid-latitude cycle in here
let's do it this way okay so there's my
warm front and here's my cold front oops
changed my color okay now you live here
and we're gonna talk about what it would
be like if one of these formed and then
moved past you over you now as is this
happening this thing is rotating
counterclockwise this front is going to
catch up to that front and this whole
thing is on the move but for to simplify
things let's just assume that the front
state just like they are but this whole
thing is going to move as is across and
pass over you okay we're going to talk
about what you would see what you would
notice now as the storm approaches
realize that we're gonna see events that
are from the warm front first then
there's a gap and then events from the
cold front next so that's one thing to
keep in mind the other thing to keep in
mind is that this El the center of low
pressure as it moves towards us the
distance between us and the El is
decreasing so what does that mean that
means the air pressure that we
experience as this gets closer to us
is going down and then at some point
that L will pass by and then as it moves
on we will get farther from the L and
our pressure will go back up
okay so there's going to be a change in
pressure in addition to all the changes
in clouds and everything else here so
we're going to kind of write down the
list of events so 1800s you're out on a
horse you're out here you have no idea
what's going on in terms of the weather
but this thing is approaching you and so
we're gonna think of terms of like what
that person would see okay so first
thing what are they gonna notice well
ahead what's ahead of the warm front the
first thing that happens ahead of the
warm front are the cirrus clouds right
so you see the cirrus clouds and then
that transitions to your cirrostratus in
your Aldo Stratus then your Stratus okay
so we're gonna assume that this is kind
of like a pretty big pretty big storm
okay so I'm gonna sign some kind of
arbitrary x to this but let's just say
that this right here is about twelve
hours okay so as you're watching this
this whole thing is on the march towards
you right
so then what finally gets to you what
comes after Stratus Nimmo Stratus okay
so that gets to you next and you're in
precipitation now what kind of
precipitation is it it's kind of us it's
like a slow and steady rain so I'm going
right down steady precip no rain or snow
could be either how long does it rain so
if you're from New Mexico you might want
to sit down for this because it's gonna
be hard to wrap your mind around you can
get 24 hours or more of steady
precipitation okay I know that freaks
people out
but let's just say that in this scenario
this person is going to get about 24
hours of constant steady rain it's not a
downpour usually it's not like a
thunderstorm we're just Marines really
hard it's a more of a state slow and
steady type of precipitation okay
so if you imagine if you can visualize
this whole thing traveling okay after 24
hours of precipitation that warm front
is now right up to where you are okay
but as this has happened there's another
thing that to keep in mind it's also
been happening ever since step number
one which is this low-pressure center
has been getting closer to you so the
air pressure that you experience down
here on the ground is decreasing so
during this whole stage I'm going to put
number three but it's happened since the
very beginning is the air pressure from
your perspective oops is decreasing so
in old school barometer talk that means
that that mercury column is going down
so if our farmer in the 1800 has one of
those what they would say is that the
the barometer is falling okay that
refers to that dropping calm and mercury
all right so we're down we're now off to
a day and a half right 12 hours of
changing clouds 24 hours of
precipitation that whole time the air
pressure has been decreasing the
barometers been dropping but now this
front is right to your doorstep so what
happens well the warm front passes so
what's that like temperatures are going
to go up so if you think back to the
ramp the bottom of the ramp now is is
passing over us and we're in the warmer
pool of air behind it so our dew points
are going to be up to okay
now from your perspective it seems like
the storm might be over so the storm
will say it starts to break up okay so
you've been in slow steady rain for 24
hours and now it's you know it's kind of
stopping and you got some cracks between
the clouds and you're in this warm
rather humid air okay so now you have to
imagine that this thing has gotten to
you and it's past you so that now you're
in in this part okay you're in this part
of the storm and you've got to gap
between when the warm front passes you
and the cold front arrives in this
sector and so in this sector is probably
very little precipitation and might see
some Sun right might be you know some
strategy mule asur or maybe might almost
be completely clear at some point so I'm
gonna continue my steps over here so and
again we're kind of assuming this is a
pretty big slow-moving storm so we'll
say half day to 24 hours of a break okay
looks like storms over then coming
behind all that is the cold front okay
now the other thing that's happening too
is this low that's been moving is now
passed over you and so pretty soon your
barometer is gonna start to rise again
so the barometer starts to rise so again
that mercury column starts going up
right so in other words air pressure
increases then cold front arrives what's
that like well immediate thing that
happens temperatures drop and we said
that along the boundary here of this
cold front that you often get pretty
severe cumulonimbus
so if I can imagine let's say I'm
looking at this on a satellite loop and
we'll see this in a second but right
behind this cold front I'd have a bunch
of cumulonimbus and as time goes on they
kind of become less and less frequent
usually so what's your experience about
it your experience of that is not a slow
steady rain but it's raining here and
not here it's raining here and not here
it's raining here and not here what do
we call that and weather speak scattered
showers or if it's snowing snow flurries
okay either one so when that cold front
arrives we're gonna get cumulonimbus so
we'll call that scattered showers right
and if it's cold enough snow flurries
okay so that goes by and now again
visualize that this whole thing is moved
past you and you're now back here in
this sector of the storm well if it's a
big one you might get 24 hours or more
of this kind of cold and stable air so
the scattered showers can continue a day
and then the next day they're even fewer
and the next day they're even fewer it
could be something like that if it's a
big storm okay so what happened so if
you can't keep track here we had a half
day of clouds a day of rain maybe up to
a day of a break and then we get a
couple days of this cold and stable air
with scattered showers okay and then
this whole thing now
is completely buying you're back here
somewhere and what's back here well
what's back there is some really cold
air that's coming down from the north
from Canada let's say and this is very
cold and very stable very cold very dry
very stable so what kind of weather is
that clear skies sunny but cold so kind
of our last step here number ten is cold
sunny and normally several days of this
okay okay that is sort of the experience
of someone on the ground who is
experiencing a mid-latitude cyclone now
if everybody in this class was from New
England or from Minnesota or from Norway
everybody would understand this because
you had experienced that many many times
the further south you go the further
away you get to the polar front so what
happens as say in New Mexico we rarely
get all of these steps in fact this is
called the Norwegian model the Norwegian
model was formed by these guys in Norway
who made a bunch of observations of
these mid latitude cyclones and notice
they formed a pattern what actually
happens where we live most of the time
and you kind of have to think of
okay let's say this is the earth and
there's a polar front okay
so we're gonna mix up air on the polar
front and you're gonna get a cold front
and a warm front so maybe at some
particular time here's the warm front
here's a cold front right something like
this and this thing is moving or you
know following basically the polar front
and twisting and all that but here's the
thing where's New Mexico in this picture
New Mexico might be like right there so
what does that mean that means that we
missed the warm front entirely and we
get the tail end of the cold front so if
you lived in New Mexico a long time you
know what this means because it in the
winter what do we get cold air and wind
and that's pretty much all we get right
our winters are pretty dry whereas if we
lived further up here in that same storm
system they might get you know several
feet of snow something like that because
they're closer to that polar front
they're closer to where those two air
masses are getting mixed up we're pretty
far from the poor front so we just kind
of get the drags right and then if you
get further south and they probably drew
this too far south because it looks here
we'll draw on a fake equator
there's my equator okay so when you get
down you know pretty much Mexico and
anywhere further south they don't know
what friends are they never have them so
fronts or a mid latitude in higher
phenomenon so in the mid latitudes and
even sometimes up towards the poles this
is where we get fronts down here
no fronts know mid-latitude cyclones
so we're going to go to this website
called NASA worldview and what it is is
they've got a couple satellites that
sort of travel the world like this so
there's always one on the opposite side
of the world is the other and as soon as
the footage comes in they post it on
this site and you can go back in time
several years and look at what the earth
looked like and these black stripes in
the middle you know the earth spins
faster along the equator than it does at
higher latitudes so the satellites
actually miss a little strip right along
the equator and so each one of these
stripes is another pass as it comes over
and they stitch them together here but I
can I can look I can zoom in here and
here is a classic mid-latitude cyclone
now that line right there that is a
artifact of them stitching these
satellite stripes together because
remember they're going around taking one
stripe at a time and then they have to
stitch them together so there's time
that has passed between one side this
image in the other so if you notice
here's this classic commish ape here's
another here's a smaller one so these
are both mid-latitude cyclones
I don't sue me in a little bit here not
that much and the low the center of low
pressure would be right there and the
let's see here
let's go so you see all this wispy stuff
that Cirrus okay so someone from the
ground that's standing over here this
whole thing is spinning counterclockwise
and moving to the east that person would
be seeing these cirrus first and then
this Cirrus get thicker and then after
that you can't really tell what kind of
cause you've got but you'd go through
the sequence we just talked about so
there's our there's our Cirrus and then
cirrostratus is right behind it also
Stratus similar behind it you can't tell
from this where the precipitation starts
the nimbostratus or you know probably
down in this part but you can't really
say for sure here
so there's all of the stratiform clouds
from the warm front and then you'll
notice there's a sudden break right in
here okay and then you'll see that right
there are these spots what are the spots
the spots are communal Memphis towers so
every one of those spots out in the
ocean is a cow towering cumulus Nimbus
in fact if i zoom in a little bit
these don't show so well you can often
see the animals they're kind of fuzzy
I'll hear some so like that's an anvil
and that's the ice on the anvil kind of
floating off so if we kind of look at
the big picture there's cold dry air
coming down this way mixing it up with
warm humid air coming up from the south
they're mixing it together right along
here
that's what's forming the mid-latitude
cycle that's the warm front stuff this
is the cold front stuff so this is
what's happening along the polar front
or all around the earth all the time
okay here's it so let's check out this
other one here okay so again you can see
there's the Cirrus right and then they
get thicker and then cold airs behind
here all those all that spotty stuff
those are all cumulonimbus towers right
behind there if I were to go to the
southern hemisphere let's see here
so here's one in the southern hemisphere
it's spinning the wrong way right it's
going it's spinning it has a clockwise
spiral to it everything because of the
Coriolis effect everything's backwards
down there but they're all around
they're all around Antarctica all the
times so here's a satellite loop looking
at a mid latitude cycle and it's going
to form right in here and then we'll see
it mature and we'll see it move so we're
going to go a one frame at a time here
and so right there you can see here
comes the cold air coming down from the
north
there is the warm air moving up from the
south and now they're mingling and now
we get that classic commish ape
that's what mid-latitude cyclones look
like when they're mature and the
low-pressure is somewhere in here and it
wraps around now you can see the spiral
that's where the low is you can see the
speckles those are the cumulonimbus and
this is all the stratiform clouds and
you can see it as it spirals it's also
moving to the to the east right so it's
headed towards the continent and so what
what can happen is especially over the
ocean the mid-latitude cyclone is
conspiring spiral and spiral so if we
tried to draw fronts on this it'd be
more complicated than the one that i
just drew the the fronts would actually
wrap all the way around here plus you
get some occluded fronts in there so
that's what mid-latitude cyclone looks
like as it then matures okay and then it
goes on to the we were back to where we
started also this is what a mid-latitude
cyclone looks like in terms of
precipitation so we're looking at
Doppler radar so all these colors are
precipitation and so we don't see clouds
here but the low is kind of centered in
here this is mostly all warm front stuff
so this is that steady rain we were
talking about
and makes this comma shaped blob of
precipitation okay so that's classic
mid-latitude cyclone precipitation
pattern let's go back to earth thought
no school done that again and so last
time we were here we were looking at
total precipitable water and so this is
where we are again and again just making
the point that that's the mid-latitude
cyclone counterclockwise rotation we're
bringing up warm humid air from below
from the south or taking cold dry air
from the north and we're mixing them
together now I'm going to turn this
around and look at the southern
hemisphere and what I notice is that
that's a clockwise spot over there
clockwise spiral clockwise spiral these
are all mid-latitude cyclones in the
southern hemisphere and you can see like
this one for example is bringing warm
humid air from the north bringing it
down and mixing it with cold
drier air from the south so this is
happening all the time around the
Northern Hemisphere and the southern
hemisphere we have these mid-latitude
cyclones that travel around in a giant
circle where the polar front is the
thing is during our let me change I'm
gonna go back here okay so now I'm
looking at temperature 700 millibars
again that's the polar front the storms
are going to follow the polar front more
or less so right now you can see that
will turn the wind off you can see that
the polar front time right today goes
kind of right through the United States
so any storms mid-latitude cyclones are
going to kind of come through this way
right now if we came back in the summer
and we looked at it in July we would see
that this pool of cold air is much
smaller it'll be way up in here so let's
do a demo of that real quick so here
I've just changed it to look at a day in
August and so you can see the pool of
cold air around the North Pole ISM
much smaller than it was a minute ago
so there's the polar front and from our
perspective it's all to the north of us
sofa mid-latitude cyclone forms it's
going to form along this boundary which
is further to the north and we are so as
far as we're concerned it doesn't exist
right so if it doesn't if it doesn't
happen to the United States it doesn't
exist so in our winter we have
mid-latitude cyclones so we say winter
storms and then they move further to the
north in our summer we don't notice them
at all but they are still around and
they're not as strong but they are up
here to the north so one more thing
about build latitude cyclones here I've
got a storm that at first looks like a
mid-latitude cyclone but when you look
at it you realize it's missing that slot
of cold air that we saw in the previous
images and it doesn't have that
characteristic comma-shaped
it is more symmetrical so this is a
hurricane and hurricanes are structured
completely differently than mid-latitude
cyclones so what they have in common is
that they have Cirrus out on the edges
ok that's similar and they spin
counterclockwise in the northern
hemisphere but they they do their thing
completely differently so for one thing
mid-latitude cyclone means it's not low
latitudes it's not high latitudes it's
in the middle
hurricanes form at low latitudes ok so
there's a there's a they're physically
in different places on the earth let's
talk about the structure of hurricanes
here so here we have a hurricane cross
section and you think of hurricanes as
these organized bands of cumulonimbus so
if this thing were the pass over you you
would have a heavy rain from this band
of cumulonimbus and then heavy rain from
this band of cumulonimbus but in but
Queen there's a little breaks I mean
you're in a hurricane so break is
relevant but it's the precipitation is
decreased in between these now that
means that air within a hurricane is
going up and feeding all of these
cumulonimbus towers all that air going
up some of it has to come back down and
a lot of it comes down through the eye
so you may have heard that in the eye of
a hurricane you can see the sky which is
true because sinking air fights cloud
formations so when this comes across
you've got relatively low pressure under
most of this hurricane and that kind of
sucks the sea up a little bit call it a
pressure driven surge then there's a
bigger effect from the winds that kind
of blow the ocean into a pile underneath
the hurricane it's called a wind driven
surge when this comes ashore this blob
of water comes ashore with it and that
is kind of what we refer to as the surge
and it can flood the coastline now
hurricanes form at low latitudes but
they actually don't form right at the
equator and the reason for that is
because you need some Coriolis force for
the thing to spin so when we were
talking about Coriolis effect we didn't
really talk about this I don't think but
right on the equator
nothing spins okay so storms don't spin
at the equator you got to be a little
bit north or a little bit south to get
the Coriolis effect so hurricanes will
spin up kind of right in around through
here in our neck of the woods and then
once they're formed they may drift
further north and in fact they get into
the area that we call the mid latitudes
right so mid-latitude cyclones are up in
here and occasionally a hurricane could
go far enough north that it could get
into that territory but hurricanes are
pretty much forming pretty close to the
equator a little bit north and a little
bit south in this region that's red this
is the area of the ocean that has the
highest sea surface temperatures and so
higher ocean temperatures mean more
evaporation which means more dew point
which
means the hurricane is easier to form
it's easier to form cumulonimbus when
you have hot humid air okay so that's
everything we're going to say about
mid-latitude cyclones this time and next
time we're going to get into worldwide
atmospheric circulation thanks for
watching
you